good evening it is my great pleasure to
welcome you to the fourth annual
worldwide alumni leaders assembly
sponsored by the columbia alumni
association as the chair of the
conference I want to express my deepest
thanks to the dedicated planning
committee Joe Erlich and Ruth Ellingham
Christoph Knox Dan Libby Ellen Polly
Jean and Eric Reid who've worked
throughout the summer in planning the
special program I would also like to
thank Susan Fagan senior vice president
of development and alumni relations a
dedicated alumna herself for her full
fledged support of this assembly and I
really want to thank the outstanding
staff of the Alumni Relations Office
especially jose gonzalez Eileen english
and jesse my god who worked tirelessly
in making all of our planning become a
reality this weekend and I especially
want to thank President Lee Bollinger
are moderated this weekend who has been
a great champion of alumni involvement
in our University it has been under his
leadership that the columbia alumni
association was established and it is
under his stewardship that alumni
programs of columbia are thriving
receiving the recognition and support
necessary for ongoing growth and
development we are deeply appreciative
president Bollinger thank you I would
like to say a special thank you to our
esteemed panelists john corigliano peter
farrelly merrick jana lewis frankfurt
and kai bowie all of whom are proud
alumni of our great University and
individuals who are making a difference
at the highest levels of business and
arts throughout the world they have
taken the time from their very busy
schedules to be with us this evening to
share their perspective and
globalization in
pneus and the arts the role of Columbia
in our ever-changing world on behalf of
the columbia alumni association and all
our alumni gathered here in the hall
tonight thank you for your participation
I know that this is going to be a very
thoughtful and thought-provoking
conversation and I want to thank you our
alumni community for joining us tonight
and I want to thank you for all that you
do to help make Columbia University the
greatest university that it is I would
now like to call upon the chairman of
the columbia alumni association Jim
Hardin who put his trust in our
committee and gave us the freedom and
encouragement to experiment with a new
format for the assembly this year Jim
thank you very much enjoy the evening
well thank you all for coming and I hope
that in addition to enjoying and
benefiting from this evenings program
that some of you will consider attending
tomorrow morning's Assembly of the
Alumni leadership wherein we have
another series of presentations and
panels by some of our distinguished
alums this information if it's not
available at your places is certainly
available on the web we have in addition
to the pleasure and the privilege of the
president of the university being with
us this evening tomorrow morning we will
hear from the chair of the University
Trustees Bill Campbell we will here at
the medalist gala dinner in low library
from the vice chair of the trustees and
the chair of the University Trustees
alumni and Development Committee Richard
Witten and the keynote will be delivered
by Jeff Sachs so we really have a
wonderful weekend planned I'm indebted
very much to Donna's leadership as the
chair of course the trick is to just
pick the right people and then
get out of the way and certainly worked
this time I share this evening with the
rest of the board of the columbia alumni
association and i encourage those of you
who are alums who are interested in
becoming involved with columbia becoming
involved with one another as alums to
investigate the CAA and if you're
interested get in touch we'd be happy to
begin to recruit the next generation of
leadership for this alumni initiative
without any further remarks I would like
to introduce and ask to come to the
podium so he can present in some more
detail this evenings panel the
university president who has been both a
staunch supporter of the CAA but also a
wonderful and effective strategic leader
at Columbia on all topics global Lee
Bollinger thanks very much Jim I'll just
speak from here so we can get started
I'm going to begin by thanking all of
the leaders who are here from the
columbia alumni association and also
each of the schools representing the
alumni associations and the various
affinity groups there are several
trustees here arman Arvind ezinne Mike
Rothfeld and George Van amson we're
always glad to have have trustees Jim
Hardin has taken on the task of helping
to create the CAA as you know this is
much needed at Columbia that is a
unified sense of alumni loyalty to the
institution as well as to our individual
schools and the college and and so on to
pull this off requires the work of a lot
of people over a long period of time
Steve Case was a very very fine leader
who began the process and Jim has taken
over and it's just a really really
important
thing and he's been great at this and
Donna Rosenthal you know it takes a
willingness to to see other
possibilities a kind of openness to new
kinds of organization new kinds of
structure and you were there right from
the beginning with that kind of might I
even say academic openness that we
surprise in the academic community and
and you helped us to bring it to where
we are today so there are many people
who have helped to make this possible
want to thank them all but let's get
right down to the work so we have a
great group of alumni with us today we
have the composer John query Liano 59sec
filmmaker and school of the arts
graduate peter farrelly great filmmaker
Lou frankford 1969 alumnus of our
business school who is chairman and CEO
of Coach fellow law school graduate
marriage' know we both commented on the
way in there it said every time I walk
into this room I get anxious because
there is in the sort of you know on
erasable imagination the risk and being
called on often I often say that I
became a law professor so that I could
call on people just like I had been a
sort of tit-for-tat so merit is a member
of WTO appellate body and director of
the international economic policy
concentration at Columbia's school of
international public affairs and on the
law school faculty kaifu League
graduated from Columbia College in 1983
and is now vice president of Google and
president of Google and greater china
you just can't put together a better
group of people to think about
globalization business the arts how it
all links up and and so here we are it
does seem okay I sort of like to go back
five to ten years ago
and sort of just ask each of you to talk
a little bit about how globalization
occurred to you I mean I remember six
seven years ago coming here and feeling
just intensely that I was woefully
ignorant about the world and I just
seemed impossible to be the leader of a
great University in New York City and
know as little as i knew in all candor
about the world how much that I really
know about China and how much that I
really know about India and emerging
countries in africa south america and so
on and and i think we've all been in the
process of education educating ourselves
over the past decade and a little bit of
that personal history would be
interesting but i'm not going to start
there i hope that you'll weave it into
your comments where I'm going to start
as where we are today right at this
moment and that is in the midst of and
in the midst of a great world financial
crisis and at times on the brink of the
precipice so it seems to me that we
can't start any place else than there
and I think we've got Kai foo and and
merit and Lou Who be wonderful to hear
some just opening comments very brief
because we want to keep this
conversationally going just how do you
see the current economic crisis how do
you see us going from here kafu do you
want to start sure I think clearly the
economic crisis affects the whole world
and we do see that in some countries
such as China where I live there are
some air pockets of insulation and in
the Internet industry where I work I
think it's not felt as strongly as some
other industries as we're pleased to
have announced earnings that we thought
were ok but the street seems to have
thought they were great I guess
everything is in relative terms
I think in terms of the past five or
five years the big the greatest most
amazing thing was really the internet I
think not only has that connected the
whole world up but it's much more than
sharing information it's about bringing
people together it's about giving people
access to information that may have
previously been forbidden it's about
accessing long tail infrequent
information it's about giving choice to
the people and it's about advancing the
state of education in countries like
China India Vietnam and others so I
think the Internet has been the greatest
factor that's broke down barriers and
connected the world together and that's
why I decided to join this industry and
i'm pleased to play a part in helping
globalization through the use of
internet and do you how do you think
China will be affected by this global
crisis there's a general view there's a
general view that it goes like this
China has built up an amazing economy
primarily around exports and now with
consumer demand in the United States
going down and and the untenable ax t of
the system the current account deficit
and so on that china is going to see and
feel and is already feeling a very
significant downturn in revenues from
the export side yeah and yet the only
way to compensate is to go to a domestic
consumption and in China the savings
rate is so high because there's so few
social social security kind of networks
that have built up yet that power of
domestic consumption so so how do we get
from here to there and what will happen
in between and everybody's always
concerned about instability in China I
mean this might as well go into the big
subjects right away and then I'm going
to turn to merit and ask her
perspectives on this business what do
you see here okay well actually I think
the China's domestic market
sprung a lot faster than that people
might otherwise perceive I think China's
export business only accounts for about
a third of the gross gross domestic
product so i think the about certainly
that export business is being heard
dramatically I've talked to some people
who are in export business in China and
their business is down forty percent and
that's a dramatic impact but the other
two-thirds of the domestic market
appears to be well and I think certainly
consumer confidence is still very good
the government obviously gives a very
strong message that everything's okay
China's insulated which i think is to up
to positive mhm on the other hand i also
got two to three trillion dollars of
money that's right to help get through
this and i think and then they will step
in when they did right i don't think any
bank will go out of business the
government will do what it takes so this
the strong if authoritarian if you're
well government I think Adam this moment
of crisis can play a strong reassuring
role so that I think China will emerge
okay despite some businesses especially
export once what definitely take a big
hit thanks Caillou mera your field is
international trade and of course
sitting on the WTO you have this M
having worked in the US government and
the in various roles in this you have
this wonderful perspective on sort of
how we got to this point love to hear
about that but also can the system of
international trade remain the way it
has been up to now or is it going to
undergo really revolutionary changes as
a result of this well I think this
period is is really pointing up the
attributes of globalization and some of
the dark side there's no doubt about
that and as little as four months ago I
was in Asia and talking to many
were arguing that we had reached an era
of decoupling I'm sure kaifu has heard
this where growth in Asia could and
would continue almost irrespective of
what happens in the United States or the
eurozone and to my mind this is clearly
wishful thinking so you think that
theory of decoupling is was I think it's
very much overblown in allusion yeah
yeah it's just overblown I mean I
certainly growth in Asia my senses is
going to help us a lot as we are in or
surely will soon be recognized to be in
a recession so it will help us get out
of there but I don't think this idea of
decoupling has proven itself to be
durable you've seen us markets go down
by about thirty three percent I think
you see chinese going down and russia
down about sixty percent and so I mean
to my way of thinking globalization is
mostly positive and is unavoidable and
the only way would stop would be because
of some major calamitous events yeah but
government policies will certainly
affect the pace of it international
trade and finance are different in their
impacts and liberalisation is different
and during the Asia crisis we had a very
vigorous debate here at Columbia among
faculty on on those differences and I
and I think they are right I do think
that the this period generally is should
be obliging us to think again about what
is needed at the national level and at
the international level to deal with
economic globalization and whether and
how we should be improving our
institutions I think the WTO is at risk
for becoming increasingly obscure but I
think that it's an important institution
that has injected a degree of security
and predict
ability and I just on that mirror cuz
that's really a powerful statement that
the WTO is at risk of becoming obscure
is that because bilateral trade
agreements are now the becoming the norm
and and rather than international trade
what is behind that statement well I
think first of all ninety-five percent
of global trade is covered by the rules
of the WTO yeah and so you know that's
enormously important there are important
areas that we're facing now that are
outside of the rule architecture things
like antitrust things like banking and
securities and so forth that's really a
national matter but and you are seeing
more bilateral and regional free trade
agreements and you're seeing you know a
tremendous and ability of the
multilateral system to reach new Accords
the part of the system that is working
well is the dispute settlement system
and that is I think a very important
function because instead of the old
confrontational approach of the 70s and
80s where big powers could could get
concessions from small everything is
rule-based and through an impartial
tribunal so to me that's a real plus but
but countries have not been willing to
come forward to each other satisfaction
I think the next administration could
you know if they chose to make it a
priority could could reach a deal and I
guess I think that's enormously
important Martin wolf had an essay in
the FT the other day saying
globalization was at risk and I don't
think that's inherently at risk but
policies could put it at risk and you
you know if protectionism were to
increase here or elsewhere that might be
so and when people say now is a common
theme again that the world has become
more integrated as a result of
internet significantly as a result of
markets I mean the change in China
towards markets and open this another
major societies I mean that's a stunning
change in the last 10-15 years ease of
travel common languages that that people
now speak all of these things have
created a much more interconnected world
and that's what we constantly referred
to by the label of globalization however
the point is made our institutions have
not in any way caught up with that
reality so we could in the 20th century
create all kinds of government agencies
to deal with interstate commerce and
labor standards and this and that
because we had a country we could turn
to to to change politically but we it's
much harder on the global scale so how
over the next 5-10 years because people
are now saying this global financial
crisis does not have the institutions
that are capable of dealing with it
coordination cooperation is great but
you know it's not enough you sit on
these international bodies what can be
created what should be created
institutionally yeah I'm not sure I have
a full-blown answer I do think that you
made a multilateral institution was
created out of a recognition that
national responses were insufficient
yeah and so you know there's a lot of
talk in this country and around the
world about loss of sovereignty
associated with these international
institutions to my way of thinking it
was an exercise of sovereignty to
establish them and and the WTO is is
imperfect as it is needs to be bolstered
I don't think you're going to see a new
I don't see the enthusiasm for a global
financial regulatory body but I do think
that there is scope for improved
coordination you know new emergency
powers there will be come
out of this period clearly a lot of
regulation and so the challenge is going
to be to think through mechanisms that
better think through the linkage between
domestic and international thanks
Barrett Lou you're on the ground and got
stores all over the place you're in the
vanguard of this how do you see it how's
it affecting you how are you going to
back away from global as a a first I do
share the view that that on the Internet
has created has helped create a much
more global oriented consumer and we
have been the beneficiary of whether
it's um and it's not only the Internet
of course it's literature it is cinema
or its world events what we're finding
is a on many common threads among
consumers our consumers who are our
target consumers are female college
educated primarily on came of age during
the Internet era and are focused on
innovation on self-improvement relevance
and value and we actually believe that
we our consumers in New York or Chicago
in many ways have more in common with
our consumers in Beijing and Tokyo than
they do with consumers who primarily
shop in walmart in North America in
terms of the literature they read the
movies they see the way they spend their
free time their aspirations for their
values so for us on we're a beneficiary
of the of this of the speed-up of
globalization with regard to on the
economic crisis which of course on
on we as retailers saw it early and you
see it if you look at traffic day on day
and you look at conversion of traffic
and we started to see a slowdown in more
traffic in the United States about a
year ago and we said in January publicly
that we felt there was a consumer
malaise a consumer recession and it
obviously has done have been intensified
by so many different of fact is I I
believe that a consumers are not going
to go back to the level of spending that
they are where they were just a few
years ago for a generation I think to
delivering that secure as they were over
they they were also they were over levin
11 it reddit cards per person it's
whether it's 11 credit cards or a sense
that of immunity against poverty whether
it was a perception that on housing
prices were going to continue to grow on
that their wealth and them stock and the
equity markets was going to continue and
with the enormous reduction in value in
global markets on everyone is affected
and everyone is taking a deep breath so
I coach re recognized on that we need to
unbe actually more innovative during
this period so that up so that we can
capture on consumers emotional appeal
that is we can appeal to consumers
emotionally when they're otherwise
reluctant to spend so what we have done
is on the product side because we're a
product driven company and I mentioned
this to you before really we've
compressed several years of product
innovation into one year and what that
looks like from our point of view is
that if you go into a coach store
anywhere in the world
in December of 2008 and you last visited
in 2007 you're going to be wowed by the
by the level of differentiation of the
product and hopefully we'll will be more
compelled to purchase than you otherwise
would it would be as if they're going
into a store in two thousand and how
many people in the audience remember
about something from coach okay a big
land please visit us during this holiday
great value hi service haha well I think
we're done thanks very much loose so
John and Peter let's go to the arts and
just so many dimensions of this that we
could talk about and one of the things I
want to get to is the extent to which
you have more and more created with a
kind of global audience in mind compared
to some period of time ago and which may
be one had a different audience also
loves know about issues with censorship
but we'll get to that let's start with
how has your own work been affected by
what we're calling the phenomena
phenomenon of globalization John well
personally I had had a very good
experience with it because the internet
and globalization has made it possible
for people to hear my music in countries
that I never visited I i do go a lot of
places five or six years ago when I was
in Beijing I lectured at the
conservatory and a young woman raised
her hand and said I'm doing your doc my
doctoral thesis on your second symphony
at first I was amazed at that just for
the sake of doing it but the second
thing was that it was not yet published
nor was there a commercial recording of
it but she had the music in a recording
of it
and so you have to see how important
that is she managed not only to get
interested in something I had American
composer that was so distant from her
world but she actually was able to find
through the internet all the information
she needed to different uses and I've
been touch with young composers from
Siberia from all parts of China from
South America on so I think there's a
huge huge difference but I think it's
interestingly the economics of our art
are changing enormously yes the
classical music when we go back has
always been an art of patron the church
or rich people or the state putting on
an opera is very expensive event and
what has happened over the years into
the 20th century is that foundations
corporations have all been part of the
donors to say the Metropolitan Opera
House rich people etc after nine eleven
there was a tremendous problem of donors
for all sorts of reasons and of
audiences and I think that we've all
realized that the large scale version of
our art has to change we will always
have the net but but many opera houses
are reducing as his Broadway if you go
to a Broadway musical now you don't have
an orchestra 40 people in the pit you
have six people in the pit if you're
lucky or poor because that's the way the
economics or fee now in the cast of
seven it's a very different world we're
living in and one of the interesting
thing is that that this gives advantage
to new kinds of art forms because
because we are directing it into smaller
ensembles of performance we now have
young composers who are not able to get
performed by major symphonies writing
pieces for these smaller ensembles
getting them published because they have
various publication things like Sibelius
and finale where they can make their
music printed making their own cds which
in the old days of the LP it was
impossible to you to make your own LTS
but now a 22 year old and beyond the web
have a website myspace a blog sell his
recordings rent is music all over the
world and so the direction has gone this
way rather than that way but it's been a
very inventive time for young artists
and in fact I would say that there are
so many young composers now that when we
always talk about classical music is a
dying field not if you count the number
of young composers there's hundreds more
than when I was here so it's actually a
very well that's fascinating of course I
have to be but is there a loss in not
having the big production sort of thing
and let me we my particular interest
right now has been fisted a long time is
the press and my belief is we built up a
magnificent system of the press in the
20th century in this country and now the
internet makes it possible for the press
to reach thousands of times more
audience members than or subscribers or
viewers of readers that before but it's
undermining the business model of the of
the traditional media that we create I
have to say I think it's a good thing so
that's that's worth that's worth
debating right let me let me explain why
yeah it's true that many newspapers I
just was down in Miami performance and
you know the Miami Herald does not have
a music critic and people are getting
signed architecture and music or various
combination like that and it is true
that the major papers are suffering but
if you have any events like that event
in miami or the opening of to do john
adams opera and you just going to calm
that you'll find more reviews of that
then you can imagine and they will be by
critics from all the papers of the
united states that you can read annular
and then blogs by interested musicians
and music lovers I think it's much
healthier atmosphere because we have a
very wide range of criticism yeah and I
guess the question would be putting it
in your own feelings whether that very
healthy kind of public forum that now
exist but it's just amazing I mean it's
the equivalent of the New England town
meeting the classic kind of model in
which everybody can come and participate
but it's at a loss that's the kind of
major production or now basically they
still happen they may still happen it's
not that you will you know their
endowments box trav endowments and the
Met yes streamlining itself a bit but
it's going to do what it does but but I
would say that the interest of the
musical community is turning away from
that as the sole goal right it's
widening itself enormously to include
smaller ensembles smaller groups as well
as these big groups data will be there
but I think it's really wonderful to see
how many more opportunities there right
thanks to technology that's got to be a
good absolutely Peter how do you see it
and well first of all let me say I'm
glad I'm speaking last because I no less
than eight limbs and all I can assure
you saying that right up front will be
the judge global economy I never heard
of it to call me two weeks ago
over what so odd also I did want to say
one thing about this crisis we're going
through economic crisis like I'm looking
at this like it feels to me exactly as
it would feel if aliens made contact
they came down and said we're here we do
exist and we're all like okay now what
oh that's why I feel like I have no clue
how this is an affect my business your
business anyone's business a sort of
we're just staring they're like okay and
what's the next move you know we don't
know what's going to happen but what I
do know is it does point out when aliens
come down that we are one people this
world you know we're all in this thing
together it's really interesting how
this is happening it's not like just the
u.s. is getting crushed and everyone
else is like you know we're doing well
there is like you know we have aliens on
all planet right now we are just looking
at way it's completely unknown so I
really don't know what's going to happen
but I will say this um traditionally my
business has been the greatest business
it really to be in America it is it's a
huge export the film business always has
been for 50 60 years every country they
wanted our movie they didn't want our
cars you go to Europe there's different
kinds of cars you know there's different
everything but they had our movies they
loved our movies and one reason was you
know people liked all things American
but one reason was they didn't have a
lot of money to make a lot of other
movies you know they didn't have money
to make their own movies and the global
economy has made it possible for all
these countries to suddenly say like hey
wait a second you know I liked Elster
about us and our people and there are so
many of you know every country you know
particularly India but now Russia and
China and and all these countries they
have they're not only investing in
America movies but they're making
and in fact 20th Century Fox just
started a vision for non-english
speaking and they're making them outside
the country and they're trying to get a
piece of that that world because that is
growing that is getting bigger and
bigger and bigger whereas you know 10
years ago you know it was all american
movies at all these countries except for
France baby and a couple others there
Germany now you know they'll have the
American movies and but they're going to
have their own movies too and when you
create a movie do you think more in
terms of the global audience are you
beginning to um you know not not really
specifically I don't think like that
honestly but I have to say like you know
we're always developing two or three
movies at the same time we have just
things and for whatever reason you can't
get the actor you want you don't want a
way to go to another movie it's always
seemed to play out in a nice way for us
and we've had this one movie that's just
been sitting there forever and we just
think we wrote it and we just didn't get
around to doing it and we've been
working on these other two movies but
one day when the economy came crashing
down it occurred to me that's the movie
we should make and it's the three
stooges and the reason is because it's
physical comedy and physical comedy
travels hugely yeah physical calm and he
plays in all countries they get it you
know right and and i think the world if
you look at like all the movies in the
30s you know after the crash 29 you know
those movies it was that kind of
physical people want to forget i want to
go to the movies now this last couple
weeks on like honey let's go to the
movies i just want to steer and forget
what's happening you know forget about
the alien yeah and so I want to make the
Stooges because I do feel that it it is
timely right now to make a movie like
that it's sorted for me the way I see it
it's dumb and dumber yeah you know I
think it will play very well right now
so i have to say yeah i did i did pick
that movie now because yeah what's
happening worldwide and picking up on
the connection
with what you do and making films and
the International Business merit maybe
you should say something about the way
in which trade currently exist with
respect to culture and film so just we
get that on the tape that is leg behind
other kinds of products right yes no I
mean the motion picture association is
one of the most organized lobbies in the
world and so they have been forceful
advocate of emanation of American films
and it's been met with great enthusiasm
and most great deal of the world there
there are a few countries that regulate
both for content and in the cultural
sense you know because they want to
preserve their culture and not have you
know the spiritual pollution that comes
with American culture and but you know I
grew up I grew up in Japan and I grew up
you know watching bonanza and Japanese
and there are many places where you know
American cultures and American media and
films were absolutely saturated so I I
don't think but there are exceptions in
China of course is probably the race how
many gone can go into China you know
it's being liberalised years ago when I
was a trade negotiator I met with
China's chief sensor at that year there
were only two films allowed and that
year he had allowed true lives and Mayan
King and I said why those two and he
said the reason was because of this
excellent special effect so maybe you
can tell me if that was the commonality
between those two but I think it's far I
think that fine and I think it will be
something like tell me you would
probably Grove a big over there
you know that would but yeah they do
pick it although of course walking down
the street you know you'll see your
movies finally was all over the place
people selling him for a buck each yeah
seriously you know any movie you want
you come on every you know practically
every corner you come up and just flip
through the things at all here that's
coming out next month of us and David
Feherty over there you have it hey
captain how about the internet and the
miscibility of what do you it with
respect to free availability of film and
commentary and music and film well I
think certainly film and music are
currently freely distributed in China
both on physical medium DD DVDs as well
as on the internet and I think it's
really going to be very important to
figure out how to move that towards a
more legal approach google for example
is going through an amazingly complex
deal to make legally downloadable mp3
files possible in china basically by
subsidizing to get the habit changed and
hopefully over time with advertising
revenue that will eventually recuperate
our losses for now but i think but you
were talking also about information and
well yes but before we get to that I
don't know pinned down which we just
then I assumed to be what when Merritt
said and Peter said which is that even
though legally there are very severe
restrictions on the number of films that
can come in in practice it is readily
available that's that's right now during
the Olympics I think there's been some
crack down but that's respect itself
composer nature and it's probably
loosening already yeah I think largely
for movies people do go buy these dvds
for a dollar on the street for music
what actually happens is people go to a
search engine
Google but someone else's which actually
supposedly caused the internet and make
available to mp3 files claiming no legal
responsibility although recently been
discovered that the search other search
engines actually pay for servers and
bandwidth on which they put pirated
copies of mp3 and make them available
only through their own search engine so
I think the legal system will be quite
stretched out how to you know show all
the forensics to prove this and and also
all the but we do hope that it starts to
come into a shape because I think it
really builds up a very bad consumer
habit that they assume everything all
that easy on the Internet is free and
everyone's doing it so therefore is not
wrong and I am very worried about that
come on right so let's look ahead from
each of your step with how you think the
world will look in five years ten years
I need to go beyond that people start to
think I have no idea but but in five to
ten years recognizing where we've come
in the last five years or ten years from
your own standpoint how does the world
look look differently John well I think
that it's pretty inevitable that we will
end up having homes where living room
walls will be scream and sound will be
all around and they may even be several
walls
we will be able to access everything
through that and all over the world all
over the world and i think that's
inevitable the ants the way things are
going and it's terrifying in a way
because the human context so it is lost
even though we could see everything they
can really interact with everything
although I do think interactive things
are starting to happen and that will
play a role in this more and more
interactive video is going to come about
but as I said the living experience of
going to a play or hearing a string
quartet or going to a concert in where
you sit with a bunch of other people and
you are absorbing something that other
people are doing and reacting to it and
talking about it that's I think
psychologically going to be a very
serious problem is that it's going to be
very I think that's a very powerful
thing to say course very powerful thing
to say in the context of a university
because because we could be in that
situation that is we can be doing
everything by that screen on the that is
on the wall and not having this
classroom and merit and I not feeling
intimidated and lock in here is our own
living room and so on and and but yet it
seems like universities are as
successful today as ever right i mean
the students are happy they're paying
and normal sums of money i mean it's
very expensive to attend these
university i always have to add that it
only costs they only pay fifty percent
of what it costs actually given that
education and of course there's enormous
commitment to helping people can't
afford it so with all those
qualifications fact is it seems to be
thriving and yet you know your comment
and what you see is a very very
interesting sort of foretelling the
future that may have an impact on future
life here yeah it would be horrifying to
me if that happened and it does seem to
be going that way because you know as
anybody who's made a comedy knows you
never want to show a comedy to critics
alone you want to show it to comedies in
a big room of people we try to pin
everything filled out we want to get
four or five hundred people in there and
the critics and they cuz they feed off
the audience they feel oh you know this
is I supposed to sit there like wait a
second did what does that nur here this
is insane you know this is a nightmare
you know what it that this they need the
audience to say it's okay we're laughing
at this we're getting this we're not
appalled because if you're sitting there
alone it's a whole nother movie really
is yeah I have to say you know yes what
it would be like in the future well I
was in China one time last October and
it was you know how many people have
been to China here yeah it was
completely different than I thought it
would be I went to Shanghai and Beijing
and there was there I took my kids with
me we went to the special olympics world
games in Shanghai and we went on this
tower on one side of the river it's a
big needle Space Needle type thing my
kids wanted to go in and up in that
space needle you're looking across the
river and there are what appear to be
100 150 huge high rises and each of them
is so futuristic like it there's like a
bird's nest on one of them and there's a
crown on another and there are different
lights and different shapes and they're
so superior to anything we have here
like it's insanely beautiful high rises
and on the wall in the in this in this
where I'm watching it from is it shows
the growth at one point that was just
rice paddies right there and it shows
the first high-rise going off
there's three going up now there's five
ten fifteen 5150 that first picture the
rice patties that was nineteen
ninety-four 1994 and it's actually this
place is exploding china is exploding
they have money and there you know it
was that you know the people or you know
it was way different than i thought it i
thought it was going to be you know
something you know that that is long
gone in the cities at least the country
it's different but we have to get into
that market we you know in my business
we can't be doing five movie beer and
selling them on the streets and so what
would you say what would you say his
students who are at the School of the
Arts right now preparing themselves for
this new world and it's some young
person who has you know come from the
state never been outside the country
which is you know sometimes the case or
if they've been outside the country
they've only been to Europe and you know
what do you tell them the world's going
to be like well you know it is it's all
about the Internet of course the
internet and produce any the cultures
are overlapping and everything's you
know we're starting to think more is one
I would say that you know it's it's a
huge advantage it's going to be a big
advantage to look outside the United
States not just us anymore right my last
movie was a disaster here came out to
nothing it was huge overseas huge and in
places that I had Poland and you know
things that you never thought of it was
just picking up so much you know
worldwide that the movie made tons of
money and and it really got me thinking
I boo you know thank God for you know
you have to be able to you can't i guess
i would say that you know you really
have to think of it as global ways like
what would appeal to to the world but of
course saying that you know nobody's
sitting down writing a movie or a book
thinking okay no or will they think of
this in China you know you right you
know something that you're
yeah hopefully it works out marreth well
I think in the next five to ten years
the u.s. is still going to be the single
largest economy in the world but you
know all these studies are showing that
the relative productivity is going to
ship elsewhere so China other parts of
Asia perhaps parts of Latin America
these big emerging markets are just
going to be the engines of growth on a
relative basis absolutely baby and so
that really is a profound change and
we're going to have to learn how to deal
with that and keep up with it and
hopefully deal with the downsides of it
the university you know I've seen in the
last five or ten years obviously more
international students more really
global students more collaboration with
foreign universities routinely more
collaborative research and that can only
just continue I was recently talking to
European academic presidents who was
saying that Europe has started you know
they had this Erasmus program where
European capital and the universities in
Europe that they've brought a chinese
university into that Network and you
know that kind of thing I think will
start to have to happen over time as
other universities develop comparable
you know credible skills and how does
this this shift of productivity to
emerging economies and place around the
world how does that affect the
geopolitics do you think I mean Iceland
makes big bets on risky investments and
ends up close to bankruptcy turns to
Europe for a loan no turns the United
States for a loan no blown the whole
Russia gives to the five billion dollars
now that has to be has to be a
significant thing in the world so how do
you see this
geopolitical very hard I mean I think
Europe has become a much more vocal
advocate for experience of foreign
policy ages than it was in the past and
it's part of you know the European and
agenda you know integrated Europe Europe
as a voice in the world so i think i
just see both opportunities for
collaboration but also a lot of inherent
tension between the united states and
europe and also i do think a diminished
financial power is a diminished power
and the extent to which we are meeting
billion dollars a day of capital
employed for foreign sovereigns it's got
to have some impact so the question is
you know will we be able to address it
by increasing our savings a question and
lou i know i assume that eighty percent
is going to shift fairly significantly
and how will this unfold from your
sample when we are look at the global
luxury market it's inevitable of the
greater china or will be the number one
market on whether it's in 10 years or 12
years there will be the largest it will
be the largest luxury market in the
world and that has enormous
ramifications in many respects and
certainly it does for the coach and we
see ourselves as of a major future
player as of the middle class of
developed in china and by giving them
products that are relevant actually in
our business we do think about what
before when we makin bank for example we
think about what will the Chinese
consumer think and what for the Japanese
consumer think in a week and this is a
round of around a within the context
globo assortment so we might Taylor a
particular style with a with a certain
color or a certain exclusive bag for a
particular market to deal with local
differences but the commonalities are
overwhelmingly the same i was in a
bangkok a few years ago and I on a on
with my wife and we stopped in a store
and what was a coach store I felt like I
was in Boston and yeah it was exactly
the same no they are consumer experience
the environment so that's coming again
really is how does that happen I mean
that the how do out is because of the
films they're watching Peter films and
listening to John's music and they and
they're all you know reading the same
thing to listening to the same thing
watching the same things or is their
kind of a inner human yearning for a
coach bag just is is there it's part of
the alien aua I don't like to think that
picture right the reality is that is
that on the people who are set trends in
fashion yeah and Don or or and followers
they're looking to the fashion makers to
help them understand on what um what's
relevant they go on the internet and
then we they go they look at magazines
and they look at movies and they look at
editorials yeah and they go to the lead
cities win on when they travel and on
they go down up and down the high
streets and they look as they look at ya
what are the people in the know wearing
in Terry and that's a very big influence
it and that's part of it and then the
question comes how do you differentiate
yourself from everyone else right and
you look for ways to connect to weed
the ways to connect with on the emerging
middle class consumers by offering
products that are particularly
innovative and relevant that shocked ice
points so let me present a proposition
and see whether you think this is true
or not American culture in all its forms
is one of the biggest things that the
United States export so as much as
people around the world may dislike the
United rates and policies and practices
and so on culture continues to be
something that appeals the coming out of
the United States Appeals and coach is
is part of that American identity and
you have tapped into that next
proposition that will change that is if
you take merits comments and and other
comments as America's economic power
changes so we'll it's the appeal of its
culture and therefore you as a business
are going to have to become more tap
into the other places of the world that
is that it is there anything to that
well your original hypothesis is
imbalance is not alpha K on a we thought
she will say that we we we actually
position ourselves as they are authentic
New York fam New York is a lewd world
city as is Tokyo and Shanghai and London
and these cities will always be World
Series and what New York represents to
people and other societies among many
things is energy it's change as
diversity there's a richness in New York
that people really appreciate and it's
not the case in any other city which is
really the repository of people from all
over the world so we tap into New York
and fashion and style that's what we do
we think that will be relevant and
obviously are we also don't rely on a
single tenant yeah we have a variety of
found foundational elements one is
authenticity yeah well made price
durability right all of that stuff like
a well-made belts there's a long time
John it has a delta that they're 20
years some coach baby longer than Rose
when time for a new one perhaps I don't
think that the other people's tendencies
are automatic declawed Jana so it's not
a zero-sum traded up zero sum and and
there is of course a blending that
happens with our culture which makes it
really interesting at we have a Columbia
alum who introduced Domino's sample and
he introduced a clam Pizza you know in
the shell right I don't think this would
work here you know that it really works
well in japan right things like that
right and i just want to say in my own
defense i just put this out of the night
yeah not as it i know we know that yeah
I want those attic I know you get the
last word before we go to the to the
audience so I mean if anybody is the
future here instead of the internet
Google is the future so what does it
look like 5-10 years okay I think the
internet saw that has really stood for
two really important thing Oh what one
is what people call this intermediation
that's the process of getting rid of the
middle agent moonlighting the suppliers
and the demand connect to each other
remove all the friction make the whole
thing more smooth and fluid and what we
have seen of course is in you know
buying stocks you no longer have to pay
that larger commission of course maybe
you are not buying stocks for a while
but in real estate you'll actually sold
my last house without a broker I've made
it available on the internet and zelda
wii was that of responsibility i being
in the officer of google not at all i
actually did it prior to joining google
and a lot of other things are happening
when you buy on ebay you're not going to
put some of the stores and amazon so and
so forth I think that will be taken to
the next level and we talked earlier
about aggregation of media I think I
think that's the same right today I
think we are very reliant on New York
Times to put together its view on what
the best combination of food critic and
Technology Review and authors and
commentaries and news articles but maybe
in the future those of us who want to
use the internet with fullest extent
will use wall street journal for perhaps
forever your favorite international
trade new york times on politics and USA
Today on entertainment and Yahoo Finance
and Google blogs and so on so forth and
you'll subscribe to the people that
whose blocks you want to follow and
whose views that you value and your you
search engine to find the things you
like and then you'll essentially make
your personalized newspaper and I think
that will start to realize that you
think that the the institution's you
can figure out a business model to
survive in that kind of consumer choice
so that's the big question I mean
absolutely question that is a big
question absolutely up but I think
whether they liked it or not it will
happen because it really is Walt
Mossberg that people want yeah not
necessarily Wall Street Journal so
either the institution's figure out the
model that they can keep making money or
their their their assets their people
will find a way to build a business
model for themselves now I don't know
what that model is going to be exactly
where suspect is going to be advertising
based and someone will figure it out and
i think the wonderful news is that
consumers will look for more freedom
more selection more power and and more
individualized content so that's the
first projection the second one is
really more about search engines right
today the search engines people think
they're wonderful but really they're
very simple what they do is there at all
they find your loss of stuff and then
you have to figure out what you want and
I think over the next five or ten years
they'll really become intelligent so
instead of being a tool there'll be more
like an assistant so today if you were
buying your mother sending flowers to
her you have to have to go through us
you can go to search engine and do a lot
of things find where the flowers are
typing your credit card number to let
the flower you want have an address it's
going to be even or 45 minutes before
the flowers are selected essentially on
the right day with the right there hard
but really it's not that hard if you had
a really smart assistant your secretary
or your your spouse or children or
whatever you tell them they get get my
mom flowers for Mother's Day they know
exactly what to do and there's no reason
the Smart Search Engine can't do that so
if use your search query might be sent
mom flowers and it will be smart enough
to figure out with my mom where does she
live what kind of flowers should I send
these a mother's day soon is the
carnation as it roses and then what
credit card you have how to charges and
whether your
want to discount or not and things like
that so of course there are privacy
issues that relate to have to be solved
as well but I think the search engines
or the internet services will have more
intelligence and will help you help you
get what you want done not just to give
you information so that you can do it
yourself so this progression from being
a tool to an assistant will really give
us the most valuable asset back to us
which is that time and do it just
finally try to like I mean I can't
resist again listening to you and
thinking about the question what happens
for us what happens to university so why
isn't it that person since there and
says okay I think I want to take
economics 101 or you know I really got
to learn about international finance and
WTO from merit Jenna so I've signed up
for her course and but then I really
want to take this person from Stanford
and then there's this person who doesn't
you know as an independent scholar and
doing that and and I put together my own
curriculum and I do it over the course
of my lifetime and if it's not this four
year plus kind of life and I working
during this time and I learned if I get
why isn't that the universe and and you
know Columbia almost emulsion died in
this room the question is who do you
drink with it yeah I let me just say I
think that is the right way I think
actually it is because one of the
benefits google offers right employee
engineers in china right is that they
can go to Bali sorry in this case
Stanford University yeah to to take a
master's in computer science Google will
pay for it yeah but the only requirement
we have is that they do it over the
internet and in the last three and a
half years that i've managed Google
China zero engineers
and I asked him why not and they said
well I do want to study in the top
institution in the world but I don't
want to be next just what we wanted to
hear it's open to the audience their
microphone I have a question for mr.
leak way over here way over here okay I
didn't realize you usually I'll stand up
but I got to sit through this English
has been the language of the internet
more or less in terms of international
trade but that still is a hindrance for
those who can't speak or communicate in
English is Google doing anything about
making translation technology available
in the future net plans lines of all I
legal tax and then we all do an
automatic translation and we now have
about 400 language pairs always you can
sort translation and go to translate
google com and that will provide that
service and also the other thing we're
doing is within search results we're
trying to do value index so research in
one language results of other languages
may
here translated results now one caveat
is that it's not very good the best
machine translation in the world but
it's not as good as any of us warranty
it is a lot better than we we blame is
roughly high school level translation
and of course we hope to continue
improving so that fifa has programs at
least 10 countries exporting the
columbia american way of looking at the
world analyzing vocabulary for conflict
resolution alright so it's
if we think about the implications
office obviously he will be easier for
people to communicate with each other if
they have the same from cabaret and they
discuss the same condition but down the
line how can we encourage more concrete
resolution that is even the Europeans
who knew each other so well still it
marked on a world war first world war
second world and so forth how can we
strengthen the tendencies toward peace
and cooperation collaboration instead of
conflict and war there's a living the
hair place to question there is a point
that period mobile was from the end of
the 19th century until World War one and
if you go back on home and look at a lot
of the cockpit for during that period
leading up to the First World War Second
World War it was a kind of paint world
much more integrated mature along the
lines that were we now of course the
first transatlantic cable wasn't and you
have a lot of things that
and yet it ended up in massive world
conflict and carnage why are we so
optimistic now that 10 years from now 20
years from now we will not have a
repetition of that and what should be
done given the sad history of the 20th
century to help avoid that you know I
has made to be important piece of that
question for merit if a sovereign
decides to default on a WTA award what
is the enforcement mechanism plus
percent compliance rate so far and the
actual penalty
I don't think it is just to follow up
the reason i ask the question is because
a lot of corporates go to the World Bank
exceed and there are 34 cases more than
half the backlog is against one country
Argentina now you go to the seven-year
process and I think seven have gone
through the appeals process and
Argentina has chosen to default now the
reason that Argentina has chosen to
default because once you go to the
appeals court you have to say that you
will abide by the appeals court decision
and I was involved in the CMS award and
Argentina's n chose to default the
reason Argentina cited that they chose
to default is because in a similar
situation the US would default so then
you see well bankex it becomes useless
those are master state claims comes on a
bilateral treaty well these come up with
the bilateral treaty
we've we've heard a lot about
globalization of markets and I'd really
love to hear from some of you about as
we sit here in this great and
educational institution about the
globalization of the labor force whether
it's people who make music or make
pocket books or write software could you
comment on what you're finding in the
preparedness of American america's labor
product whether it's our high schools or
colleges are you going abroad for your
labor or are you going abroad for your
labor and if you are is it because you
need people who know those markets or is
it because they're better cheaper better
somehow more favorable as labor law here
to go to England and sorry you're hungry
its aggressive various countries that
have different laws without reporting is
because our fight strict reason so
people go other places sometimes with
sacrificing quality
by three true that in certain ways the
music union has been on silent about
understanding that for example if I
absolutely ratter tale world collapsed
and they already know more companies it
had been made a profit selling it so one
of the greatest benefit opera because we
Adele has managed to break through at a
time very very strongest renew around
and leadership and then able to have
these telecasts over the world and other
than what he / say I said woody seawater
you have you know what I have let me
here is a world situation in which
America certainly starting to come to
grips the office that they are not being
cheated for example if a you're reading
session of young composers acumatica
operate the recording that means I'm
gonna make a baby our daughters this is
starting it's very recent and not all
officers but I think Peters not a great
thing in breaking through the biggest
hardest of all that to make
communication logs that we are all and
then back we have to father it
software than a dancer sort of two types
of dr. dogs back to New England globally
one is more the development of very
simple software the average job
developers well spy program or testing
of a program for doing a solution for
company that kind of got it was very
clearly impossible primarily India but
also to China and the kind of things I
have observed in the industry is that
for about a third of the cost we can
move the software development elsewhere
so what this really means is those jobs
for the time being will be challenging
in the United States all the overtime I
expect they will be eventually be in
equilibrium reach because access because
of shopping so easy move now for the
type of work at Google in ages name is
very high-end we do have 45 in R&D
centers across the world and and we are
more or less the number one employer
normal all of these 45 countries and
it's interesting observe that about half
of our labor force is still in the
United States which is a strong
testament of power in education
institutions in the US and also the
creativity that graduates have a new ice
pop it and that's something I without
thinking about our ability to you flew
across and loan based upon what our
requirements are and the manufacturing
side we have migrated primarily to
lower-cost countries that have degree
eight a less expensive product to market
passing on savings
siemens and giving ourselves a better
term but the technical know-how we have
exploded with us so that we can ensure
the quality would be there similarly the
materials we exploit on the other hand
at the invidi are at retail in 27
countries where we actually market our
products we like to develop local mohab
and I look to develop local staff and
only when on only during the commission
of formative stages who we rely very
heavily on X hats but as we become
established on we look to transfer the
leadership through our people with the
native to the country what's in the
region which means that creativity
there's going to be more more often like
we have time for one more life the weed
increase with increase mobile dangerous
hidden some international discussions
would be wgo the robin platzer popular
musician at conejo that pharmaceutical
patent should be moved norwich may
fights in medicines for those in
developing nations the rationale being
that one kept with a 21st century
society without medicines it's possible
that in about 15 years ago or so the
same do regarding this issue with
patents will be put forth regarding
computer software to the agenda engine
as we were primarily issues computer
software principle be able to compete in
I must be just ignorance quite analogous
technology and software space but
certainly very thought wondered what
would that be not sure either but I i
believe the patents for the software
industry is absolutely critical to
maintain in order to assure people
companies invest in it are able to get
returns on their investments however I
think making salt to it really available
disregarding action can be separated
into the issues but the way in which i
can add in third world countries that
need access to some say email for the
kid in school they can be provided for
free remember me at still maintaining
the litigation as an example Google
provides basically free Google
applications which includes out a word
processing application stretching and
email up to universities basically and
we can we can also do that and also with
the universe
and i think the world and oriented
presentation on friday evening problem I
think those applications were quickly
and easily so this was really
very engaging enlightening and
distorting presentation and also a
wonderful after nation as we can give
you 190 10 of our alumni in the world
now the other part of the Friday evening
gathering is a little bit of relaxation
and reception and there are some guides
that will direct us out of the doors in
the back toward